all right the corporate media is in a
bit of a tizzy today uh they're always
in a tizzy but they're especially tizzi
today after according to their headlines
Trump confessed to being a dictator
during a town hall with Shan Hannity
last night and in the town hall the
media says Trump announced that he would
be a dictator on day one in office and
as it turns out that is actually what he
said let's watch the
clip I want to go back to this one issue
though because the media has been
focused on this and attacking you under
no circumstances you are promising
America tonight you would never abuse
power as retribution against anybody
except for day one except for he's going
crazy except for day one meaning I want
to close the border and I want a
drill drill that's not that's not
retribution I got I'm going to be I'm
going to be you know he keeps we love
this guy he says you're not going to be
a dictator are you I said no no no other
than day one we're closing the border
and we're drilling drilling drilling
after that I'm not a dictator okay that
that sounds to me like you're going back
to the policies when you were President
right I love that clip I mean that
that's V to me that is vintage Trump um
and I don't think we've seen a lot of
vintage Trump this cycle unfortunately
but that to me that's like that you you
that if I had known any better you told
me that was from
2016 I would have believed you because
that's like 2016 era vintage Trump and
um and so see that glimmer of uh of that
and it's great and I love the clip for a
bunch of reasons first of all because
Shawn is uh like doing his thing acting
as campaign manager rather than
interviewer trying to lead Trump into
saying certain things like this is not
you know even if you're a trump
supporter and maybe you're happy that he
gets a A softball interview it's like
this is not even what Sean Hannity does
it's not even an interview this is like
walking him through the things that he
it's
a is it so Mr Trump Mr President your
here's what you are saying right now
here's here's what you're saying and
ch's like no I'm not saying that so Mr
President you're what you're saying is
that you're this stuff about you being a
dictators that's you're not a dictator
no I am at least on day one that's
great and then Sean starts panicking uh
and the whole thing is
fantastic of
course now what Trump is actually
promising to do here is not
illegal um it's not retribution it's a
it isn't actually
dictatorial he's not saying he's going
to suspend the Constitution and throw
his enemies in
prison that's what Biden is doing right
now so if he did say he was going to do
that then all he would be doing is is
continuing uh the Biden administration's
current
policies but he's not even saying he's
going to do that he's just saying that
he's going to ruthlessly and effectively
wield power to move his agenda forward
and to do the things that he has the
power to do and that the American people
will have voted for him to
do and um that's what he's saying you
know and he's saying it in a funny way
and it's it's it's giving Sean Hannity a
contion fit and it's giving the the
media a contion and so it's a lot of fun
the October 15th tax deadline has come
and gone and I know many of you may be
dreading filing uh your taxes and all
the stress involved filing your taxes
can be a long excruciating process but
if you fail to file you'll start to pile
up penalties on top of your tax debt
that's why you need to check out tax
Network USA the team of tax Network USA
is a track record of success they
produce tax debt for numerous clients
totaling over $1 billion whether you're
looking at a $10,000 or a $1 million tax
debt they can help you with a settlement
doesn't matter if you haven't filed in
one year five years even a Whole Decade
tax Network USA is equipped to secure
the best settlement for you the tax
attorneys and professionals at tax
Network USA can help resolve all tax
cases no matter how they started don't
let debt control your life any longer
take the first step towards resolving
your tax issues by visiting tax Network
usa.com Walsh that's tax Network
usa.com Walsh today my problem with what
you just heard
there my problem with Trump's dictator
comment is that he's only promising to
do it on day one because if by dictator
we mean again just ruthlessly and
effectively wielding legal power to move
forward your agenda and crush your
enemies well he needs to be a dictator
in that sense every day of his term I
don't want day you know it's day one
what about day two and three and four
and
five this has always been my critique of
Trump's presidency a lot of people even
to this point after these many years
like they still don't understand what my
criticism is okay I know a lot of people
criticism of trump and the left it's one
thing and you got the never Trump
whatever crowd the bill crystals of the
world who've become leftist or always
were but have uh fully come out as
leftist in response to Trump like
there's that that's that's not my my own
critique is is quite different it's like
the opposite of those
people
um they say that he was a
dictator what I say is that he didn't
wield his power nearly
enough like he he was far too eager and
far too willing to cow toow to the left
and to the media and too desirous for of
their um
approval you know they paint him as this
ruthless
like uh you know
pragmatist who's just out there getting
stuff done I I want more ruthlessness to
me he was not nearly ruthless enough in
the first
term
um and so I liked his response there but
what I would like to hear in the future
is this is what we're doing day one
here's what we're doing day two day
three day four day five it's not a day
one thing because also by the
way those are not things you can do in
one day anyway obviously it wasn't I
know he wasn't speaking in in in literal
terms here but building the wall all
these kinds of things you can't do that
in one
day
um but what I would love to hear from
and you kind of hear it there is this is
like the attitude that you want which is
that like I don't care if you call me a
dictator or not sure sure whatever I'm a
dictator that's kind of what is doing
here he's doing the same thing that I I
always say you know you should do when
someone calls you transphobic or
whatever because you're saying that men
aren't women rather than rather than
responding as most Republicans and
conservatives do by say I'm not
transphobic just say fine okay I am I
don't care like if that's how you define
transphobia is that I believe in um
biological reality then sure I am I
don't care this is how you define
dictator as someone who actually wields
his legal power to move forward in
agenda that you oppose if that to you is
what a dictator is then yeah I'm a
dictator fine go ahead call me that it
doesn't matter perfectly fine cool yep
that's what I'll
be and so I think that's kind of what
Trump is doing there and
um I'd love to see more of it thanks for
checking out this video if you'd like to
listen to my full podcast on the go you
can check out the Matt wall show on
Apple podcast Spotify or wherever you
get your podcast